the protagonist of the film is a genius
frenchman named alexander the movie
starts with him trying to peek into his
neighbor's room he is trying every way
to get close to her showcasing that he
is the ultimate simp after brainstorming
a bunch of different ways he comes up
with a mastermind of a plan when his
neighbor is on a vacation he uses the
opportunity to change her room design
and install a two-way mirror with this
kind of mirror everything is transparent
from one side while the other side looks
like a normal mirror he then breaks the
walls between his apartment and hers and
replaces it with the mirror after
everything is set up alexander's
neighbor returns from vacation she
assumes that the newly installed mirror
has been set up by the landlord and
doesn't think much of it she also
carries on with her usual routine
oblivious to the fact that she is
constantly being spied on moreover the
place is arranged in such a way that
alexander can even listen to her talk
for several weeks he watches her sleep
change clothes talk to herself and do
many things she would never have done in
front of another soul he finds out
everything about her life her habits and
her routine he also particularly likes
the fact that she likes to dance alone
and talk to herself it would be kind of
sweet if it wasn't so [ __ ] up the
scene changes to five months ago when it
all started alexander actually already
has a fiance named lore it is
valentine's day and the couple is
exchanging gifts however when alexander
opens his gift he is upset to see just a
pair of ordinary slippers lore kisses
him to try to calm him down but one can
clearly see on alexander's face that he
is no longer passionate about lore and
is bored of their relationship desperate
to get away from such a life one night
alexander visits his friend's cottage
which lies on a beautiful beach to his
surprise as soon as he enters the place
he notices someone trying to break into
the cottage he hides for a while and
witnesses a beautiful girl fan fan
entering the house through the window
the girl starts making herself
comfortable as alexander watches in awe
soon after he confronts her and calls
her out for being a thief fan fan
defends herself and reveals that the
cottage belongs to her grandparents tai
and maude furthermore she also tells him
that she is a student at mod school
training to be a professional perfumer
and an expert in smelling various scents
after confirming her identity alexander
also discloses that ty and matt are his
close friends with the owners away from
the cottage alexander and fanfan are
forced to spend the night together in
the same room that only has a single bed
the next morning they are rejoined by
tai and mod who are very happy to see
them after taking a bath alexander takes
a look at fanfan talking to mod he has
always been attracted to her but seeing
her communicating with her grandmother
makes him even more impressed the
following day alexander returns to his
apartment and discovers his fiancee in
the bedroom dressed as an italian call
girl laura's plan was to excite him and
rejuvenate their doll relationship
however she is met with disappointment
once again when alexander ignores her
entirely before leaving the apartment
she invites alexander to meet her
parents later alexander arrives at
laura's house where he is warmly
welcomed by her father while talking to
him laura's father asks him to join his
family's funeral arrangement business an
annoyed alexander asserts that he does
not want to join the business and also
feels upset hearing laura's father's
bleak perspective on marriage somewhere
else fanfan is with her friends telling
them about a handsome man named
alexander who she is in love with she is
willing to approach him in a romantic
way but feels like something is stopping
him from going all out at the same time
things are more difficult for alexander
he explains to tai that all of his
previous relationships have had the same
disappointing pattern once he gets
physical with a partner the passion that
was at the beginning is invariably
replaced with regularity and boredom
when asked what the alternative is
alexander responds with platonic love as
his suggestion he mentions that he will
woo fanfan for all of eternity without
ever confessing his love for her in
order to avoid the dullness of coupledom
in his new relationship with her he will
never kiss or engage in physical contact
with her since he believes that
excitement comes from unsatisfied needs
a true simp indeed he will remain
physically with lore but he will never
stop longing for fan fan the next day
alexander takes fanfan to a random
apartment and arranges for a lovely
dinner when she asks him about the
apartment alexander lies telling her
that it actually belongs to his father
he has prepared almost all of fan fans
favorite cuisines for the dinner while
enjoying them fan fan shares some deeply
private secrets about her body and life
after she is done talking she asks for
the way to the bathroom but alexander
struggles to show her the way sometime
later the phone rings and a lady speaks
in german fan fan grows suspicious and
asks alexander if the apartment actually
belongs to him alexander tries to lie
but when fanfan mentions the lady
speaking in german and him not knowing
where the washroom is he is forced to
tell her the truth to their bad luck the
owner of the apartment returns home with
his wife and is surprised to see an
unknown couple enjoying dinner in their
kitchen while the wife tries to contact
the police alexander and fan fan flee
ruining their wonderful candlelit dinner
after they are out of the apartment
alexander blindfolds fan fan and takes
her to a television studio where a set
depicting vienna in 1813 is located she
dresses up in a beautiful white gown and
the couple begins to dance while gazing
into each other's eyes the romantic date
is disturbed when alexander gets a minor
cut on his lips when he falls from a
height hence they conclude their
adventure-filled evening with a bottle
of champagne on an imagined balcony
overlooking a beautiful picture of
vienna alexander proposes a toast to
their pure relationship but titles it
friendship the comments annoy fanfan so
she asks alexander to drop her off at
her friend paul's house he is a sculptor
who is currently working on a body
design of her later alexander returns to
his apartment and is surprised to find
lore waiting for him preparing a list of
guests for their marriage when she
notices the cut on alexander's lips she
suspects that he is cheating behind her
back cheating with a porcupine maybe
strangely alexander acknowledges the
fact that he actually did meet a girl
but reassures lore that nothing will
ever come of it she listens to him and
trusts him wholeheartedly in the
following scene fanfan and alexander
hang out together as friends on a beach
in the heat of the moment fan fan gets
undressed and runs towards the ocean
into the cold water moments later she
returns and asks alexander to put some
sunscreen on her back too which he
agrees while alexander is rubbing the
lotion we can clearly see that he is
attracted to her unfortunately just as
he is about to kiss fan fan lore
unexpectedly arrives by boat she
excitedly mentions to him that the
wedding preparations are almost done
furthermore she also announces that she
is pregnant with his child fenfan is
taken aback to learn that he already has
a fiancee and that she's pregnant as a
result she slaps him hard and walks away
distracted by everything going on in her
life fanfan fails her final exams at the
same time alexander comes to know that
laura actually lied to him about being
pregnant and he is furious at her in a
fit of rage he throws away the wedding
invitation cards that laura asked him to
mail to their relatives after alexander
discards all the wedding invitations
laura herself calls off the wedding
later alexander looks for fan fan and
finds her boarding a boss to italy he
desperately tries to chase her but gives
up after some time then he visits tai
and tells him that laura's called off
the wedding tai claims that fan fan will
be in italy for 10 days and suggests
alexander go after her immediately
alexander who has decided to get her one
way or the other begins to formulate his
next strategy he rents an apartment next
to fan fans tears down the partition and
sets up a one-way mirror so that he can
see into her apartment while remaining
unnoticed oh yeah i forgot about how
creepy the beginning of this was after
10 days fan fan returns from italy and
back to her apartment she assumes that
the newly installed mirror is set up by
the landlord and doesn't see it as a
problem on the other side alexander can
be seen keeping an eye on her from that
day onwards it becomes a habit for him
to watch her every day fan fan is fond
of dancing and she often practices alone
while looking at her mirror sometimes
alexander mimics her from the other side
fan fan also has a habit of talking to
herself every night alexander silently
watches her and places his finger next
to hers although he can't feel it fan
fan wakes up the next day and takes a
bath alexander walks into the bath too
admiring fan fan through the glass
surprisingly fan fan takes the
initiative to call him and apologizes
for slapping him earlier she then tells
him that they can still be friends and
hang out together alexander is happy to
hear this and even happier when she asks
him to spend the weekend together again
at the beach cottage as friends however
the next day at the train station his
happiness turns into disappointment when
he finds out that fan fan has come with
her sculptor friend paul to make matters
worse fan fan reveals that she and paul
are now a couple later on the train to
the beach cottage fanfan and paul can be
seen happy together watching this
alexander is filled with jealousy as fan
fan seems to have moved on shortly after
when paul goes to get some juice
alexander informs fan fan that he and
laura have split up and that her
pregnancy was a lie however fan fan
asserts that it is now too late later
when they arrive at the beach cottage
house paul declares that he and fan fan
are soon to be married alexander is
heartbroken but can do nothing to stop
them after the trip both fanfan and
alexander return to their respective
apartments paul is also with fan fan but
when he expresses his desire to stay
overnight with her she surprisingly
replies that the show is now done and
paul's mission is over alexander who is
watching everything understands what is
going on it turns out that their wedding
plan was just a deception to make him
jealous and that fanfan is still in love
with alexander later on tai has a long
chat with his wife and cannot keep the
secret about the one-way mirror from her
he asks her to not tell fan fan but mod
cannot keep the secret from her
granddaughter and tells her everything
about the mirror in her apartment
shortly after fenfan returns to her
apartment and asks alexander to show
himself when she threatens to break the
mirror alexander comes into her view and
tells her how much he loves her they
softly kiss through the glass and try to
feel one another but fanfan claims that
she wants more she pleads with alexander
to come to her room but alexander does
not speak a word fan fan threatens him
with yet another ultimatum if he doesn't
enter her room by 10 o'clock the next
day he will never see her again when
alexander doesn't arrive fan fan leaves
a letter stating that she's going to see
her sister and moves out of her
apartment alexander arrives at his
apartment and when he does not see fan
fan on the other side he rushes to a
room and reads the letter he immediately
calls mod and feels devastated to learn
that fanfan's sister had died a long
time ago and the only way fan fan can
see her is by committing the unthinkable
he is heartbroken and blames himself for
being too late to touch fen fan's living
body but to his surprise fan fan smashes
the glass wall between their apartments
and smiles at him alexander is so
relieved that he rushes towards her hugs
her and kisses her the movie ends as fan
fan tells alexander that he has time
until dawn to win her back subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching